hello everyone this is the bouillon and
today I'm gonna be talking about
something very interesting so I've been
creating an SCP content for six years
now and in all that time there has been
one comment that has been very common in
those six years and it goes something
like this when are we gonna get a movie
or a Netflix show based on SCP now the
Netflix part will never happen but
thanks to Lord bong we have a really
kick-ass
animated series thanks to forlorn find
REE we now have regular filmic content
but there's one more thing that is yet
to happen and not as an extremely well
produced almost blockbuster like movie
based on the SCP foundation are not only
based on the SCP foundation but based
around scp-096 arguably one of the most
popular SCPs
ever I would say so
a bikepath good news there is a
gentleman called clay ably professional
filmmaker on visual effects artist who
is making a film about scp-096 and it
looks absolutely out of this world it
looks like something you would see in
the box office if you want to see the
next Avengers movie as I'm talking about
it I'm gonna be showing you screenshots
production screenshots from the movie
and most importantly what zero-nine sex
is gonna look like and I think you'll
agree with me it looks absolutely
amazing clay ably has produced probably
more than you think when it comes to SCP
stuff if you go to scp-106 on the wiki
he actually created the art for that he
has created multiple posters for the SCP
foundation that I didn't even know he
created until a few months ago so this
is an example of this still image work
that he does and this is a movie that he
has already created based on the SCP
foundation called sight 22 this one is
based around a not yet created SCP
although I have heard rumors that
they're gonna be turning this into a
real document so that I'm looking
forward to but just looking at this
footage I mean it speaks for itself
really I don't really need to say
anything this is the kind of movie
content that I would have loved this
thing and believe me when I say this is
a really rare opportunity he has
launched a Kickstarter I'm not sure when
exactly he started it but as this video
goes up there is less than a week to go
so the reason I'm making this video is
to try and help him reach that goal on
Kickstarter because this movie is gonna
be at me isn't trust me if his previous
work is anything to go by
I think he's slightly over halfway there
but I think in a week if everyone that
watches my channel just gives him a
dollar each he'll easily reach that goal
so please consider giving something to
this because this short film is
something that the entire community is
gonna absolutely love I guarantee it
so that's enough flattering of clay for
now to end this video I'm just gonna let
clay tell you a little bit about himself
on the short film he's producing and I
hope you consider Baca time on
Kickstarter thanks for listening hi this
is clay obli I'm a filmmaker and VFX
artist based out of Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania I wanted to share with you
a little bit about the scp-096 short
film our story picks up shortly after 0
9 6 is rican tained after a gross breach
that led to many deaths and what could
have been a catastrophic event the SCP
foundation is investigating the cause of
the breach and is reviewing the footage
with dr. Daniels who was the head
researcher of scp-096 at the time of the
breach things begin to look shady as
interviews unwind
if you're a fan of the SCP universe I
encourage you to head over to the
Kickstarter page and check out more
information there I'd like to thank the
Volgin for giving this project a shout
out and I look forward to bringing the
shy guy to the screen Cheers
you